all right let's do this thing ladies and
gent hit the music even a Neela Klein
and post balloon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what up EPS what the [ __ ]
Bikaner oh that conference is tomorrow
night about that holy [ __ ] did I hear no
heckling cuz it's I'm against that
policy bro heckling am I logged out of
this computer yep
alright right how off to a good start
we're logged out of our computer here
Alex need your password Oh how's
everybody doing tonight wow this is
insane
[ __ ] you know did anybody like come from
a far distance to be here how far what
we got fingers over here what was that
Missouri holy [ __ ]
did you oh my God thank you God bless
you dude that's do we have a password
check on the computer who else
long distance what do you got
Philadelphia what up pips damn you know
thank you guys Oh whose birthday oh
happy birthday thank you so much god
bless you
is this gonna is the past we're gonna
pop up if I don't touch okay all right
thanks Alex you're fired by the way
[Laughter]
first of all uh thank you guys all you
guys could be doing anything in the damn
world right now and you all chose to sit
here with our goofy asses so that means
a lot and obviously post Malone hey guys
my [ __ ] unbelievable I'm [ __ ]
absolutely terrified okay sing every
night I'm Tara I am so scared right now
because I want I'm gonna count how many
words either says no you uh you know
what up you have anything you want to
say no perfect yes so ela so ela I do
want to say Austin post Malone this guy
is so ride-or-die he's always there for
us and like for you to show up on our
first live show to grace us like this
and
get that much more special I honestly
just want to say huge huge thing you
mean I love you better thank you brother
thanks for having me and I just hope I
don't bother anybody with my presence
that's not righteous kick-ass time is
this live right this is double life
there's so many layers to live from this
there's a live stream which we usually
live stream our podcast and there's a
live audience is there are other layers
of life that where I'm not we're going
to get live living people
is this my water does Austin water okay
the password in the water
we're like listen alone is showing up
we're gonna need at least 12 beers at
his side Bud Lights and we and they
delivered on that there's definitely not
12 are you serious how many times do I
have to fire you tonight is Bud Light
sponsoring you yet by the way I don't
know I don't think I could talk about it
oh that sounds promising
shut up the Bud Light bite alright let's
get started you know I was driving in
here today and I don't know how many of
you guys saw this there was a giant
billboard you know pulled that up would
you that said it really was just like
hey I mean I just took this literally
driving in well you gotta move that
window this we're not used to this setup
this is our first time here doing this
so you this is important I need to make
sure that you guys actually see this
like as close there you go the projector
is really hard driving in just here
today syphilis is serious I'm like Jesus
Christ what's going on in Hollywood like
I know it's serious but like what do I
am I not supposed to breathe here like
how serious is it apparently there's
another one that somebody said there was
like gonorrhea we'll get you there's
like an epidemic in Hollywood of STDs so
make sure to they're free the checks are
free and the STDs are free food yeah s
fees are free depends on who we had a
long conversation here on the podcast
once about bugchasers were you there for
that I don't think they're yeah there's
people out there that they love catching
the bugs and specifically aids like
they're they'll go like take a dip well
they get it you I was talking about
there's like aids parties yeah yeah okay
yeah probably I mean I don't know who
else you'd be talking to about that they
go to these parties and there's one dude
with AIDS and everybody just [ __ ] each
other and then one other person leaves
with AIDS a gosh it's like aids relax
yeah AIDS relay arts like it sounds like
a bonus stage of a really awful game a
great [ __ ] deejays casino [ __ ]
slot machine
how you doing post how you been lately
I'm good you're about to start a big
tour right you're sure sure thing
did you told me you're getting this can
I do this yeah yeah yeah I'd smoke first
ask questions later you know I mean [ __ ]
Dave Chappelle does it yeah that's true
well I guess there's a technicality when
you're performing that like you can say
it's part of the performance you're like
okay it's an act it's an appetizer I
don't actually smoke I want to have a
cigarette but my mom is watching exactly
but if my jewel at home it's just an act
mom cardinal sin leaving your jewel you
told me that you're doing like selling
out 20k Cedars like when we when we
first hung out for the first time I
remember you
white are white Iverson had already gone
real big you hadn't even dropped your
first album yet that was about a year
ago that's it's insane how how far
you've come in that short years been
unbelievable yeah man I'm just trying to
kick some ass I mean 20k is and I'm
[ __ ] this is terrifying yeah yeah
we just need to Jamie people here this
is like 200 yeah hopefully it's not like
a Mobley it's not like a multiplying
with every 200 how many people are
watching on the stream at least 10
people chat oh you those people ten
people round of applause for if I'm
watching a home all 10 of you and my mom
I wonder air oh and shredder shredder
shout-out to my mom who's watching
shredder we were gonna bring him with us
but we're like oh my god we're going we
can't have a shredder at a restaurant
kind of wanted to set up like a little
cage here and just keep them in there
but we're like that's not that doesn't
make sense
that's insane we just figured that out
last night - more like yeah like don't
take him on any Delta flights or
whatever they - what the [ __ ] bro okay
let's talk about that thanks for
bringing that up so if you guys haven't
heard apparently us family had a puppy
little cute adorable dog that they
brought on a plane you're supposed to
put him under the seat in front of you
that's how you bring a puppy on a plane
and the stewardess was like you need to
put it on the overhead and insisted you
got put on the overhead I mean this was
a whole failure of on all sides because
they first of all they put it on the
overhead over a 3-hour flight they never
checked like hey is my puppy not [ __ ]
dying if it came down to me putting my
dog in the overhead compartment I would
definitely after takeoff get him hey
yeah well anyway spoiler alert the dog
died hahaha
really light no just start it off with
which especially broke my heart cuz
we're just so in love with our puppy
shredder and just I had a dream last
night where shredder got run over by
cars lighten it up a little bit more you
save them you save them in the dream
yeah it's less traumatic if I say that
though anyway how do you not check it
how do is has a story you put a puppy in
it overhead I don't know this world is
so puppy Shanor does not care but maybe
I don't know she being villainized
probably probably her names out there
they don't
[ __ ] anymore under like this lady who
lives at this address is it on her or
the stewardess or the owner well how do
you I mean I want I'd like to place the
blame all around cuz how the hell do you
put it how do you put your puppy and an
overhead for three hours yeah I want to
ask you something okay
I noticed you when I met you you were
rocking like you had like insane jewelry
I remember you had like a Rolex that was
like a bling the [ __ ] out with diamonds
and I feel like you don't really wear
jewelry anymore not tactical I'm going
for tactical nowadays
what do you mean tacticool tech okay
yeah I don't know I'm still [ __ ] with
anymore yeah it's the old thing for me
changing the box yeah but I still wear
my Mike Michael retainers and [ __ ]
my golden retainer sounds way cooler
than grill definitely start calling them
retainers the December first has passed
and your new album has not come out what
the hell man what the hell last time you
were on the show we were being what my
life was being threatened by Patrice
Wilson on the show right now I don't
hear I don't like that he knows where I
am
he's a trenchcoat waiting for you I'm
looking at the exit is there emergeny
Patrice Wilson escape plan did art we
don't know there's not I could tell you
y'all better [ __ ] human shield my ass
if the trees kicks through those doors
if true fans will take a bullet for me
no but that was so funny because you had
said your new album was going to come
out on the first did I say yes cuz okay
yeah okay yeah a lot of people don't
understand yeah
I'm hilarious ya know a lot of people
just don't get it that's the case
because like billboard and all these
like huge publications like Oh
beer bongs Bentley's drop in December
first and then when it passed everyone
was soups like this [ __ ] you yeah so
what happened was I mean I just want to
make sure everything's fine and right
and sounds good and [ __ ] yeah I was
gonna ask when but I just wanted to ask
when yeah well now it's probably better
I just thought was fine December first
guys of this next year this year how's
the apocalypse bunker going have you
mentioned tactical yeah yeah
keeping tactical my doggy it's going
good my dog how the [ __ ] do you do my
dog
how about [ __ ] the idea of my doggy yeah
it's going good man we just had some
month some contractors come by the house
and take a look and hopefully it's a go
this Mike stinks a little bit sniff your
mic good after a show smell it up your
never be so disgusted when you so is
that your own stink because do you say
no guys the Mike before you use it I
don't know who because there's like
stink on these my yeah you like and you
put it right up to your mouth boy like
there's [ __ ] talk about I mean what
was it syphilis is a risk it's serious
did they not get the memo here if you
get an alert like they got in Hawaii
that a bombs coming to LA syphilis bomb
syphilis bomb has come to LA more
dangerous than nuclear crafty nowadays
with their with their bomb-making so
what do you do do you have an escape
plan
I don't know kinda you don't want to
share it you don't want see that's
exactly but you guys are all invited
since you're here so he doesn't really
mean that I have a lot of dogs istic Lee
it's just not possible to get you all in
just survive what's that survive on dog
food for the rest of our life look
pretty good it's pretty good now it is
now it is there's like gourmet [ __ ]
chef for dogs like you have Ramsay has
yeah we get him meals yeah a little dank
little [ __ ] chunks of meat I'm like
[ __ ] dude oh my god it's like steamed
broccoli
my dog has this Buffalo he eats Buffalo
strictly Buffalo buffalo like wings no I
like Buffalo buffalo meat
got buffalo meat necessarily it's like
buffalo meat infused right you know I'm
gonna have to get in a regulation on
that shredder deserves only the best do
we have we had I think there should be a
caller somebody word that yeah hey guys
I don't I don't know how they got in but
uh here hold on a minute I think I can
patch a man one sec a caller
I think there's he says he's like an old
friend of post like a friend from middle
school seriously who is it hello are you
there hello oh it's not work I can't
hear I can't hear you is this I have a
feeling this is somehow Ian's fault
hello we're maxed out oh no my god this
is oh my god
not like this we're maxed out you know
the weirdest thing happened we are
testing this earlier and it comes out of
that projector in the middle roof now
what the hell who does the pole this
mystery call the top setup at all oh
I'll work on it we're gonna work back
around all right well we're gonna work
on that but there's a guy just some guy
who happens to know you from middle
school who had a really funny story
about you who wanted to call in so I'm
really looking forward to getting
serious guys STD check org get over on
the free STD check Oregon really I don't
know what are you supposed to check
yourself online sandy rub your dick on a
the computer CD Drive or something yep
you got it you guys want to I want to
pretend to smoke one of those okay you
sure are you guys mad if I have a
cigarette cuz I always calm it's like
look like I'm so just so naturally
smoking yeah do you want sorry guys
don't don't take that as me telling you
to do it just
pretending to do it I'm not actually
smoking we're performing right now got a
lighter okay thanks thanks buddy
preciate this is not me by the way guys
you guys been following the Martin
shkreli story Friends of the show by the
way
farmer bro let me light one up for him
Bartz Corelli you guys know that that's
the guy who hiked up the prices on like
a life-saving aid road 5,000% Pharma bro
what's so crazy like a couple months ago
he called he was live streaming at the
same time we were having a podcast and
he called in right after his sentencing
came in and he was like here well here
you can pull it up he called into you
you ain't called into the shard how are
you just a little refresher how are you
feeling really 0 to 6 months and no fine
is it is that zero to C so the dude
interestingly he didn't get in trouble
for raising the price of the drug he got
in trouble for defrauding investors and
a hedge fund he gave him a cute little
fat it was a tiny little bit misleading
fact the hedge fund was supposed to be
worth a hundred million but it was
actually worth minus thirty three cents
that's not a joke just so it's a white
lie yes so uh recently oh wait pull up
this clip this is a great one this is a
wonderful setup for where we're going
here oh wait so oh yeah he went so he
was out on bond he's like hey I'm only
I'm only gonna have to pay I'm not
containing money and I'm just on like
house arrest for like three months so
the genius tweets this out the Clinton
Foundation is willing to kill to protect
its secrets so she's on her book tour
try to grab a hair from her I must
confirm the sequence I have will pay
five thousand dollars per hair obtained
from Hillary Clinton and payment after
this sequence matches good
patrollers so that so I mean he's
kidding but the judge was like dude
you're a menace to society because
there's [ __ ] Looney Tunes out there
they're gonna go try to get her hair and
cash in on that so they're like you're
going to jail buddy I'm revoking your
bond so they sent his ass to prison and
he's been awaiting his I guess like
further sentencing and got away for a
million that's pretty good for someone
release no debe you had to go to jail
how much time would you do is this
related to your situation
thirty thousand dollars and I Flickr
answer with sarcastic so he was joking
around like I made a hundred billion
bucks and I'm only gonna do a little bit
of time aren't they the [ __ ] coolest
and I've long suspected that that
interview was used against him by the
prosecutors cuz that was the last
interview he did before he went back to
prison right and they're like look at
this guy's beg he's bragging about it he
has no remorse he knows what he did he
hedged his bet and so the the judgment
just came out god bless the you know it
you know the guy maimed his way right
into the into prison man seven years in
prison for this goofy as [ __ ] you know
is I suspect if he wasn't such a troll
he probably might be fine right they
made him give back his wu-tang album to
yeah I don't know how that how that
entered in they're like you know what
dog you're not worthy [ __ ] you we want
your [ __ ] I don't know it's owned by
the state maybe and well at any rate so
we made a little uh we made a little
tribute to him so our editor Alex worked
real hard on this we wanted to say a
fond farewell to a friend good friend
and Martin shkreli friend of the show
good guy he named his way into prison
and into all of our arts as well so if
you guys could hold up your phone lights
just in Memorial for a guy before we
roll this ad that mean a lot to me and
him as well
and you guys get your phone lights out
please this is
special moment yeah thank you oh my god
this is do you ever see this from this
is like magic this is incredible bro do
you see a Coldplay concert oh my god I
feel like I feel like God non-human
primates are kind of these pretty
precious animals that's why we care so
much about ROM B if you could make a
hundred million dollars but you had to
go to jail how much time would you do is
this related to your situation now
totally totally unrelated coming out of
this with over a hundred million dollars
right now I'm looking at zero to six
months so six months and no fine that's
right the so-called Pharma bro has been
sentenced to seven years in prison marks
greatly
[Music]
well he lived the same way he was locked
up memeing tip my beanie to him so sad
thank you for putting out there that was
special can you guys just leave those
out for the rest of the show okay yeah
random applause good job Alex blend that
together I felt good okay do we have our
special caller Dan our random just
totally random guy who decided to call
in give it another go why don't we so
yeah we got yeah we know what we're
doing we're prepared me neither sure
come on don't miss as I was saying a
random color who knows Austin from
middle school history how did he get in
here is he on is he live oh no
projectors played sound I don't know why
does the projector have a little speaker
if you're gonna put a speaker at least
make it louder than that what do we do
Dan oh we're gonna we're gonna take a
break about halfway through this right
yeah okay
whoa man Opie sticks around this random
kid Opie's committed it's great
maybe I think it's yeah alright so
random sweatin this mic smells really
yeah look if it a sniff I don't think
you sniffed it
mine's fine yeah mine's good yes
definitely mine
maybe it's me maybe I'm just finally
smell on my own nasty mouth clip has
failed me no they're great
I would never disparage quit hey here's
a headlight or just so uh I don't I
can't work the leaks here oh that man
this was a huge [ __ ] man this rock the
whole [ __ ] planet I hops putting up
signs all around the saying will not
serve seat guests with strong marijuana
odor
it's a seat guest and by the way it's em
where'd you [ __ ] races
please we need to contact I hop PR we
need to do that we need to pull all
their ads and shut down YouTube
unrelated but that always happens
that was funny you're so funny
thank you so funny thank you man alright
well we've got a video on deck let's get
right into it we got all kinds of funny
cringe videos to watch together
by the way you can imma I'm a huge shark
fan I love shark game hit me with the
soundboard Dan do you have it is he
gonna come another projector you know
then the UK shark tank is called Canada
how's that Canada no heckling it's the
same it's all part of the Queen's
Queen's [ __ ] god bless the Queen
why what's bet what's more aggressive a
shark or a dragon who a dragon dragon we
should do a collab so they brought this
shark the shark - shark dragon crib
that's too scared no one enter that den
so they brought this guy out who's his
pitch to them is literally a pyramid
scheme which is so funny because the
producers knew exactly that they were
bringing out a guy and it's not even his
pyramid scheme it's somebody else's so
he's coming out trying to recruit these
sharks into underneath him in another
person's pyramid scheme and it's just a
whole [ __ ] romp so let's let's let's
enjoy this together shall we I get back
here
[Music]
yeah movin into the den a Brampton
Ontario truck driver with an all-in-one
card that rewards shoppers and he's
hoping the Dragons will become investors
this is so [ __ ] cruel the producers
to bring this guy out man
hello dragons my name is Andy nachus and
I'm from right off the bat
very seedy that suit it's just I think
it's his collar I think it's best
imagine taller bro I did the collar is
very Elvis impersonator wait say see his
sign man
straight from Ontario up I stand humbly
before you today to offer you a
historical business opportunities
historical ladies and gentlemen our New
York for Andy I'm looking for a hundred
and seventy five thousand of your
hard-earned dollars which works out to
$35,000 per dragon as I would like all
five of you on board what do we get how
much of the company if you could please
let me finish my pitch I will lead up to
it I haven't [ __ ] you Kevin it's not
yeah [ __ ] you Kevin can you please not
interrupt me you [ __ ] Oh Oh a dragon
maybe if you were a shark I'd listen but
today he's a dragon Kevin is not yeah
Kevin Kevin is not [ __ ] with what a
product that I'm selling okay go ahead
thank you very much man you're so nice
early it would like all five of you on
board in exchange you will get a
business package within our rapidly
growing company this business package
will be responsible in the near future
for bringing you huge returns
[Music]
opps I'm ready to sign uh let me explain
lioness brings shoppers to retailers in
a form of a cashback card
this is going to reward you with a lot
of money in the future I love this
billboard it's like a bad pop-up ad on
like a porn site not that I've never
been Bruce from Krawczyk look at all the
cash she did she's [ __ ] loaded she
didn't have to invest you just [ __ ]
job instead of all these reward points
cards with clutter and restriction with
one card lioness guarantees you cash
back into your bank account after your
routine purchases they're already signed
up how much did you sign them up where
oh yeah we're in I'm ready to sign up
names are on the card
we actually I am a spokesman for lioness
and people be hand going around passing
out sign up for huge money mop
money-making opportunity just can huge
return yeah thousand dollars from each
you I stand here humbly he's so humble
it can vary it can go from twenty to
forty percent
wait a sec can I go buy something I get
twenty percent of the purchase value in
cash yes sir
that ain't gonna have your son of a
[ __ ] this is the most gullible person
alive not only did you believe that your
you can actually get twenty percent back
on a purchase he can't he was so
enthused he came on the Dragons Den to
pitch it it's incredible
to start to story so humble absolutely
keep going
so thank you sir you should be sweating
Kevin sis the way it works is that the
shoppers sign up and register for free
and so this'll not I wonder if he's just
nervous or a psyche to it I just
realized I'm being scammed right just
hit me this may not be fully up or how
on up and up music [ __ ] is my collar to
be serviced I know this is gonna end
badly for you I want you to know that
yes very badly Arlene I got to know how
I get 20% off my retailers we're gonna
hear if we got him talk let's get him on
the podcast feel bad yeah yeah I feel
kind of bad he's getting suckered like
that's the shoppers register for free
it's making man
lioness partners up with retailers in to
take a sales commission of the sales
they generate that particularly retailer
depending on their profit margin just
like a commission based salesman in a
company I get it I don't get it I get it
Robert so slow I'm gonna try to I know
if you guys watched Shark Tank but
Roberts always like I don't get it
he's like the slow he's like the Robert
seems a lot meaner on the Dragons Den it
was really nice on the shark yeah he's a
sweet he always has a puppy mmm
everybody always gives them to Republic
I feel like you always get [ __ ] from
well no he's I don't know I like Robert
I like Robert I do and Mark I feel and
Kevin's nice Kevin straightforward I
feel bad for Robert cuz nobody ever
wants to make a deal with them he's like
I'll give you two times what you're
asking and Mark's like 10 cents are like
mark mark I feel bad for the other
sharks sometimes they always going that
it's always mark I'd make a deal for
Mark whatever he wants man I don't know
what I got to offer well I'll make a
deal you're out there you met mark mark
is a good guy oh you went to a
I'm askin mavs kid how was it he was
nice oh we're clapping [ __ ] yeah man
you sat like front-row Center with him
it was nice did you guys chitchat or was
it all oh he's very he's a very nice guy
very cool guy to you no I did not I
provide always I tried to get them in on
this line as a Omar listen buddy did you
22:40 I stand here humbly this is
historical mark could I get the
megaphone can I get in through the
megaphone I have a great opportunity for
everybody in the audience half time half
time humbly historical that [ __ ] sold
my being scammed right now Blaine to you
in a simple term if I can help you sign
us up and then the deal is we should go
sign up other people right absolutely
sign up other people or eight years old
is in Europe and a pyramid scheme Falls
up part at the bottom correct because
every time you move to the top the
supporters I can see right at the office
when Michael Scott's like it's not a
pyramid scheme like you had to come on
national television this is a bad moment
to realize you're in a pyramid scheme
just like your collar my dude just look
here you'll see the pyramid from this is
the shoppers which register for free
right and there I love this shot it's
like if you in case you miss the sweat
right the producers in backwards so like
okay close up with a sweat get in make
sure you can see the pulse okay good
good good and they do this [ __ ] to where
they cut it up to make it more awkward
yeah he's like slick for a minute and
they cut it out
they're like nobody talk just get a
silence I don't make any money if
someone signs up underneath me yeah I do
the one that I bought is $10,000 and
that's to start in Canada alone Andy how
much have you return on your money have
you got now so far I'm on my way zero
because I've been very busy on years ago
G he's on his way to zero you'll get
there someday buddy people are so
gullible it never cease to amaze me how
many sociopaths are out there to take
advantage of this poor sweaty son of a
[ __ ] do you do you think he has bad
intentions or is he just a common Elvis
impersonator he seems he seems pretty
dull he's like and he's yeah he's a
useful idiot hope he's not
[Music]
Carlos Carlos is in on this already man
there's a person on Twitter
impersonating Carlos and everyone thinks
it's real and he's been like [ __ ]
talking me on Twitter that was like
shots fired Carlos is [ __ ] on you on
Twitter and I can't I can't shoot back
because I know it's just a pause you
don't think it's Carlos I mean the guy
DM me he's like hey don't tell anyone
oh really I brought us here today good
actor all it takes so much but Carlos is
off the map which is kind of a shame
because he's kind of a gem
yeah he's perfect perfect man no they
have Carlos on the that's my dream
number one dream guests to meet Carlos
yeah I just I just want a good big
connect for him he was on John Oliver
did you guys see that like man these
memes are really taking off - this is
serious stuff
Marcee Carelli from prisons like these
meme thing has really taken off dude
let's wash this idiot Phil give him the
10,000 look at that face just look at
that face man hang on let spoke to me
just want to take that in for a minute
basically it wasn't in steps the last
payment I made was about three months
ago or I board money against my house
why because the returns overpower any
percentage it's a walk yeah I feel bad
you know you feel bad it's like these
people who are getting scammed like
they're they're so committed that
they're they're unwilling to face the
fact that they like waste it's the same
[ __ ] with big connect we're like big
connected this scheme where once they
disappeared they're like no no guys you
can use your [ __ ] big monopoly money
to buy our new bit ex connect coin and
like people are so accepting yeah yeah
ex can roll they made another crypto
disconnect disconnect this yeah but it's
like God man anyway anyway guys like
unrelated but we are working on to think
a new crypto called Fupa coin it's gonna
be really big I know you guys aren't
global at all I mean I think you guys
are super smart really cool people so
Ian will be taking like if you guys want
to get in the ground floor $10 for a
FUBU coin right now and I think I
already put my house against ya take
your houses million smoke oil it's a
historical historic I humbly bought 10
million turns coming
the returns when you give him 35,000
wait a second why would an Wester give
$10,000 to somebody and never get a
return you're gonna get a return you're
guaranteed your return and as soon as
you find your for direct boom he's
saying you need to sign up for people
under you so you can start making it and
I love in this guy's mind is like who
better to get up under me than the
Sharks they're totally gonna get on that
do you think this could take off if they
actually invest it do you think it could
be a real thing no because you can't get
the 120 percent yes 10.12 they're like
if you spend a million dollars this
month you can get $10 back by the way
that reminds me you guys have savings
accounts anyone here have savings
accounts gonna get a round of applause
for savings account you've seen that hey
yeah hey response never seen a
responsible savers you ever seen the
interest rates on this [ __ ] are we just
being scammed by the whole [ __ ]
planet the interest rate on savings
account is like point zero one two if
you have a million bucks in your savings
account Bakke of America will be
gracious enough to give you fifteen
dollars and they'll also send you a tax
form too so you can report that to the
IRS
we're gonna need seven dollars in that
fifteen dollars I love the way you say
interest did I say it funny interests
interests yeah three syllables intra
interest interests not a baker showing a
lot of interest in just a Bitcoin
investors hanging on for dear life
interest I see a lot of things wrong I'm
dick [ __ ] I'm Dyslexic
just look I'm just not a job listen
admission you need to wear a badge
I need a badge well you have a Kara
badge right anyway like I don't we
recently did a stream a couple days ago
with this guy who had cancer was looking
for a bone marrow transplant and he has
a paper that he has to carry around we
were talking about this on the way down
like everybody has haters no matter who
you are
and this guy was like people are
[ __ ] on us accusing us of scamming
saying like oh my form of cancer is
nothing to complain about I'm like damn
dude even even you guys a couple of kids
trying to do some good in the world's
getting haters yeah and he had a little
piece of paper on him that was like from
the doctor that was like I actually have
cancer so he could pull that out at any
time anyway the point is that I
I have Ella she's got the care badge so
if I'd ever need its backup you look at
me like I am his this man scare he is
dyslexic and syphilis is dangerous in my
wallet serious right next to my ID they
take it everywhere next year was like
FBI ID yeah someone's picking on Ethan
you just [ __ ] with that [ __ ] hey be
cool dude easy sensitive it's very
fragile my ex-wife in Europe what
happened oh no no no no oh my god we're
having so no Oh panicking we don't have
sound in what happened okay that's on
the problem oh it's coming out of trying
to hear if it's actually coming either -
are you [ __ ] kidding me why you so
coming down the projector now now we
can't even get senator the laptop what's
with this projector now the call is
gonna come through the laptop oh that's
a good point
all I see is guard still there he's down
the line this random dude sorry you guys
weren't did any did you guys say that
you're in the splash zone
it's just like a Gallagher show there's
a spot it's like Shamu there's a splash
zone here Dan I haven't heard anything
from Dan does he may be okay
we're on our own well as long as my
voice doesn't come out of the projector
will be fine
yeah we're in good shape as long as that
doesn't happen I mean I can come up and
try and fix it that can be the show
that's me I think it's pretty got it got
it yeah why is that it's it's it's a
it's a it's a street food business I
mean Andy weir here's the way it works
just simply they're losing us line us up
here okay here's the beautiful pyramid
dragons under me and there's a Bigfoot
above you about the squashing hold on
can you finish that analogy for me so
that's it's you yes
here's lioness here's me see an actual
scene from the office when I got real
life it's unbelievable such a special
moment I wish we had that scene from the
office can you send it to me Dan or
whoever Ian
send me that scene from the office so we
can all enjoy how [ __ ] similar it
actually is and here comes the five
dragons underneath got it and they start
to build their network yeah and that
gets kind of bigger right bigger because
everybody that you bring in they're
gonna bring it here yes you understand
can we get back to this this nasty
p-word the pyramid scheme which is
illegal
yes number one well it's just it's just
I use it as an analogy you know what
many people do my friend this is not
something that I would ever invest in
and neither should you have you have I'm
out I don't know if it's a pyramid or
not but my reaction is I'm not
comfortable selling this to any guys are
so sweet yeah I'm not I don't know if
it's a pyramid
I'm not comfortable it's like dude
you're it's a pyramid scheme
Marc would have been cussing them out
yeah where's but it is Canada - how do
we get the other sharks
how can a shark be a dragon how do you
send I think we figured that out already
my friends while our business associates
so I'm out
and he I don't think you should take any
more money and invested in this it might
not be a good idea I know absolutely no
way would I put money into this OOP
forget his sweaty ass faces I'm out lot
saying goes it doesn't impress me I am
NOT a parrot I think it's just a bunch
of the sad guy with tons of angles lots
of sweat he put it in the most polite
way I think impress me they were yeah it
does you know I actually want to find
you guys need to understand how closely
this resembles Michael Scott here right
there I feel like this can't be missed
yeah raise your hand if you want thanks
thank you whoever put this video
together
welcome to these ads for pyramid schemes
underneath what works when did you two
become Facebook every this is totally me
when I see a poster pyramid scheme so
flow like Antonio
I'm leaving for you everybody in the
video so flow every oh yeah yeah I mean
listen you guys I don't know if you guys
remember the hot single so full like
Antonio that me and Austin started
working on he's down to make a cameo
yeah Joey salads is down the Bradbury's
there Bradbury's are down slammin piece
we they offered Coby person's gold cars
really really well word is really word
is we can also get a verse from Martin
shkreli out of prison like ODB just take
something off the wu-tang album all
right now we are getting three people
each the more people to get involved the
more people who are investing the more
money we're all gonna make it's not a
pyramid scheme
it's not even a scheme this is
alarmingly similar to what we just
watched good people so um here's the
deal
I guess we'll run to a quick break try
to fix technical difficulties with this
mystery guy who really persistent Dan
are we good for that we can try to
settle that out okay we'll be back in a
short brief break we're gonna roll one
commercial you guys don't have to watch
it I don't know what you guys are gonna
watch but it's gonna be so you get to
well it's gonna be so dope all right
moving along you ten dead air roll into
a [ __ ] goddamn brick we'll be back in
two minutes
oh hello there I was just shopping for
some post Malone tickets on SeatGeek
here yeah oh this seat right here is a
great deal cuz it's in green and also
has a ten rating that's how I know it's
the best deal hi guys I'm Ethan from the
h3 podcast and I want to thank our
sponsor SeatGeek today SeatGeek is a
website that aggregates tickets to all
kinds of events so that you can enjoy
music shows sporting events pretty much
anything you can imagine
they've got tickets for now here was
what makes SeatGeek so dope
they'll show you the view from the seat
so you know you're getting hooked up
with the best seat none of this uh well
if a fat guy sits in front of you nope
they can't predict that but like if
there's a pole in front of you or it's
just further back than you thought
that's not gonna happen
cuz you get a picture you know if you're
getting a good deal cuz it's green and
they rate it based on a 1 to 10 score I
love seeking I've used other services
like this seeking is by far the best in
fact it I'm so at peace knowing that
SeatGeek has me covered that I just like
to chill out and recline so I'm just
taking it easy because I'm just so
stress free now here's the offer I have
for you guys if you want to go to a post
Malone show
if you want to go do anything psychic is
gonna hook you up with $20 off your
first purchase so even if you're gonna
go buy tickets somewhere else you get 20
bucks off boom right here with seat kick
with the code h3h3 that's the best deal
you're gonna get anywhere use the link
in the description to download the app
and just remember if you're not getting
seat geeked you're getting seat
gackt stephen god you're getting seat
god I don't know how I missed that it
was such a layup even Dan from the back
was like god you're not getting seat
geek you're getting seat god so thank
you for them for sponsoring us I hope
you'll support our sponsor to help
support our show guys thank you so much
for watching let's get right back
into it I want to say the price just so
people can appreciate how laughing
Rebecca
hey everybody welcome back we continued
without you
you didn't have the time or patience to
come here in person we continued without
you mom we appreciate it on lust can I
say the price or is it too embarrassing
it's all in line well so this mat cost
$3,400 alright can you not say man don't
buy Mac Mac shamed well I have some
great investment opportunities for you
after the show
3400 to him I feel like we need another
M word because M - M tour anyway so she
let me get to the point she got this Mac
and I'm like alright let me try this
[ __ ] see I'm like very good pretty
slick the two fingers is in sand like oh
yeah I'm like where's the click button
there's a [ __ ] click button I'm
getting angry like I know you click the
mouse pad I'm like oh my god feels good
anyway my [ __ ] I was like how the [ __ ]
do you scroll she's like no you just use
both fingers [ __ ] works red how do
you put a CD in CD mmm that's right you
know how do you put a CD in
but now I'm like ela I'm like I'm like
listen ela I'm gonna need the Mac for
the next 30 minutes just watch TV or
something so I get it I don't know it's
converting me I like it it feels good
it's very [ __ ] like oh god he's got
this [ __ ] where I'm like where's the
double click they're like no no you just
click with both fingers so Ethan has
this like gaming keyboard your hey now
you're a tin yeah well I don't that's
why I don't like gaming laptops cuz it's
like lugging around like a whole [ __ ]
like it's like what's the point of
having a laptop if it weighs 30 pounds
and you need like you need like Ian to
carry it around
because you're too delicate to carry a
mouse if you really want to game like a
real gamer boy you have to carry your
mouse and I agree
that's keyboard is not tactical neither
no that is not gaming laptop is not
tactical yeah that's it you drop it put
[ __ ] and get [ __ ] blown up one
second there's no way well I do feel
like a gaming laptop is more likely to
stop a bullet for you this is body armor
conversation interesting it's
fascinating that was like one out of
three maybe one out of three tough crowd
so much better when you're in a studio
and you can't hear when you're bombing
tough groan tough crowd okay don't like
the MacBook [ __ ] banter better move on
[ __ ] all right let's take a call from
this kid is really persistent so I just
call him Dan better answer goddamn you
had his number so quiet why is it so
quiet can I call it fake why is it so
quiet speaking hello okay hang on
hello say something how the hell did you
get this number
he gave you this number hang on hang on
I know this [ __ ] you said you know
hang on you said you know Austin from
middle school can I hear all the fishes
in the audience give us give a loud yell
for Jordan drop drop hey Jordan you got
one oh my whoo
bring that mic bring there was one water
we got you double mic teared Jordan help
Jordan how the hell did you get this
number
this is a disaster
[Music]
so what the hell do you what did you
want you wanted to say something no no
Spallone it's not bail post bail are you
saying that that hold on hold on hold on
hold on Jordan I'm gonna have to cut you
up are you accusing post Malone of
ripping off Jake Paul he's definitely an
inspiration than my music but I wouldn't
say I ripped them all I know how are you
gonna sue on Jake's behalf that doesn't
make any sense
I mean post was making music before Jake
Paul like two weeks ago maybe three two
weeks ago Jordan Jordan I don't know all
right Jordan we have time this is a
short show how many Bitcoin do you even
have okay you know what we tried our
best guys are real do sure I think he
was threatened yeah I think he was
threatening you he had some he stayed on
the line for a long time you know I want
to stay the original joke we had planned
for the end cuz it's so funny and so
awful really but if I feel like if I say
it and believe me the visa what do you
mean play joke would that we were gonna
say was like and I don't want to cause
any pandemonium in the crowd but the
doors are locked from the outside
boom back we're like maybe maybe that's
in poor taste it was in poor taste
not anyway that let's move on
[Laughter]
yeah guys can I get a can I get a whale
for my pickup artists out there man
I listen one of my favorite things on
the Internet are pickup artists whoo-hoo
some men don't know how to talk to women
and they need to be instructed by some
big-ass pimps who know to [ __ ] touch
touch some titties and inevitably these
guys they're my favorite man they they
put on seminars for guys even more
gullible than they are I want to say
pathetic but I feel bad for them in a
way yeah they're not all pathetic man
yeah I mean they probably [ __ ] like
crazy they're probably I mean they're
the ones with syphilis but I have a
couple of my favorite pickup artists
lined up we've been trying to make a h3
video about this guy
Rob's from battling with this mic oh
that's kind of cool such a rockstar yo
this guy is a living meme he I just I
don't know his name I just call him the
Indian pickup artist I've been sleeping
on these clips for so long but I feel
like all the men out there and the women
possibly two are gonna be really
inspired by what you're about to see
don't worry i'm exo's this piece is
[ __ ] awesome go back to what I did
there go back over to the very beginning
don't worry about it
so first of all let's appreciate his
editing here and like
I don't know where the necklace routine
nice little blur on the text can I
pretend to smoke on those cigarettes
Austin it's just it's a carrot on top
just be clear do you get this fake
cigarettes it's Hollywood you can get
whatever you want it's Hollywood boy
including syphilis all right everyone
comes pre-loaded a pre-loaded and I get
a pack of Camel crush and one syphilis
please spits in your eye
thanks man what do I owe you it's free
it's on me you look like a bug chaser me
not you oh I got bucks if you want cuz i
am i got it i got the knitting bug real
bad which one
knitting bug biddy yeah I love the net
are you serious what is that when the
[ __ ] did any knitters in this
[ __ ] man
we got a knitter here is that is that
Logan Palmer so looks like uh it looks
like a what do you call maverick do you
pave your own path bat I would never
want my Jake Palmer tonight I didn't
know how I would go over that's pretty
funny how we take it from you what yeah
no you know I have more do you think I
would give you all my Jake Palmer are
you kidding me dude what do you knit
Osgood what what do you knit gloves
mittens work can you make me a pair
really what how can you make me a pair
sure feel like that has resale value
vodka loves knitted by post Malone will
sell like ten each one for my going
price is 40,000 I'm on Etsy you can find
me
Malone knits bro you would sell those
you would [ __ ] sell those for sure
yeah all right we'll talk so anyway
that's very grandma of you let's
continue something I learned from a
woman who did this on me
works like a charm so most women will be
building a neckpiece or something like a
necklace or something I have to
appreciate this guy's commitment cuz he
set up this presentation for all these
guys who paid he's like most women would
be wearing a necklace this one that I
happened to have the pre-planned is not
wearing a necklace we're gonna improvise
every woman is gonna wear a necklace
yeah so which kind of invalidates this
whole point if the woman in your own
presentation isn't wearing a necklace
one of three woman wears a necklace
you gotta have a slick repertoire
anyway this gets good it's gonna get out
get out your notepads everybody
gentlemen watch close don't worry I'm
not checking your boobs but this piece
is [ __ ] awesome bro don't worry I'm
not checking out your boobs but this
piece is [ __ ] awesome now like why my
question was like why well here listen
listen to his rash I'm getting ahead of
myself do you see what I did there
so I injected the sexual terms I start
talking about boobs and all but I didn't
stress on boobs I stretched on this
piece it's [ __ ] awesome by the time I
moved back by the time I love that he
has a tease sister I wonder what the
acronyms spells like stands for
implication get him out on the back the
only thing that so what basically he's
saying his point here is that if you can
distract them and say boobs somehow
that's gonna help you seal the deal
there's like you say boobs but you
divert their attention and say necklace
so they remember that you said necklace
but not boobs and somehow the fact that
you whispered boobs in their here is
that makes them more likely to sleep
that's killer gonna be register in their
mind as [ __ ] awesome [ __ ] logo and
say everybody I'm gonna check in your
boobs
this piece is broken awesome oh yeah
what did register with you this time
[ __ ] boobs right but at the same time
what I'm doing is am I'm gradually you
know leading her into that hole I'm
gradually building the sexual comfort
you know I played this part of Don Juan
and he said this that what he enjoyed
with women was like he would go to women
and these women would hesitate and he
would lie he loved the whole process
where he would lead women inch-by-inch
to where he want them to be and the
place where they didn't want to be and
that causes he enjoyed what do you think
is my inch to brush what do you think
she got a Craigslist do you think maybe
she's like wow I wanna [ __ ] you right
now
or well actually there's a video I don't
have where he like he's like so dude do
you think this worked and she's like
well it doesn't really make sense he's
like well with all due respect I'm gonna
disagree with you disagree with the girl
he's like listen guys this [ __ ] works
don't listen to her listen to me
well anyway listen I respond your
opinion illa but you really don't know
you're here
this is how y'all met yo the joke I had
for the h3 video which we never end up
making it's one of those video you
record and you throw it out because it
sucks but this joke we had was pretty
good he was wearing like a cool belt and
I was like I'm not checking out your
vagina but this belt is [ __ ] off the
chain so the more but anyway there's
another one so you start with this one
you say boobs in front of them that
apparently enchants them to want to get
weird and wild just create some new STDs
together that was the T and T's the T is
for touching a woman same thing with the
hair there you go touching a woman's
hands number one what's the e for figure
it out I just get an erection erection
its first you touch your hair then you
just go full-blown ur ass and it works
every but don't worry I'm not touching
you I'm not looking at your boobs but I
do have an erection and that's the e
that's the E is syphilis and the E is
escape or emergency the a is for a quick
game for a kiss anyone want a quick game
for a quick kiss
[Applause]
madam applause you guys are great what a
great audience I changed my mind about
you guys you guys are great audience say
you can't go back and forth between myth
and crowd you guys are it's quiet quick
up here so this is this is when he
really went to Mir I'm just gonna skip
to then cuz he has this killer line but
you know what you know what I'm not
gonna shortchange you guys it's fifty
seconds let's watch the whole damn thing
thank you playing with the hearing
audience that's level two you one thing
never do this I love your hair good
obscene guy dude especially if he has
hair tied up men will go okay I love
your hair but why do you just do it
like how bad at social interact like
you're paying someone to tell you like
okay don't do this I'm sorry but I mean
I'm we're already married so like you're
to get out of this relationship is gonna
be more effort than it's worth you at
this point
I got it locked in guys divorce is a
[ __ ] trust me yeah it's just cheaper I
gotta hedge their bets
anyway like how how are you sotius cuz
that you need to pay someone to tell you
not to grab somebody
Barry is the answer really bad it's way
to a real carrot nope had a couple too
many whiskey's you know it was a long
night couple too many whiskey's or too
many beers all of a sudden
thank you Mary kara goddamn it
how's the salt oh wow this one's much
better thanks EULA you're the best
where were we I'm trying to figure my
[ __ ] out yours is cool I like yours you
can handle my first reaction to speak is
not like leaning forward should we all
hold it should we just go handheld you
just hold each other's mics I feel like
this maybe this is probably funnier in
theory than Oh give it up it's too much
effort I hate to keep you guys waiting
or waiting this is gonna get I'm gonna
notice her hair's really nice so I'm
just talking wow you got really nice
here works every time
I'm not gonna go pull her hair I'm not
gonna go and say oh I like your hair
it's really nice
none of that [ __ ] okay by the way what
you're doing is it is pretty much just
as creepy as all the other [ __ ] like
don't do this just do this thank you for
Ferb modeling I uh I'm going easy on you
anyway the great line is coming up right
here wow they're really nice here
sometimes have you been open and women
right here I'm just gonna display tear
it you got really nice [ __ ] hair with
that good you've got some really nice
[ __ ] hair
and I love the cursing the unnecessary
cursing just to let him know you're a
little that's how you know what if it's
like a good clean Christian girl that's
never gonna work well you know he's got
the skulls on his sweater he's a bad boy
he could tell he's a bad boy a threat so
you know it good Christian girls are his
target Demoman it's true so up next now
he goes out on the street and shows you
real live footage of him picking up
cuties and he swap follows this girl
round for like an hour as he brings her
back to his motel and there's one scene
from here that I thought was
particularly compelling and I think
you're all gonna learn a lot from it so
go ahead and play this you guys get out
your notepads and the ocean is the
raging fortune
that's the audio that's his audio in the
video I'm just want to say how much
different he looks without a beanie I
know and it all came apart not the same
[ __ ] dude what you couldn't tell
underneath the skull sweatshirt is he
looks ripped he's got a nice bod he's
got a great nice flowing head of hair
but then you get this this is this is
what you get for the class you've got
some really nice [ __ ] hair
thanks how do you how did you feel about
that
so anyway let me turn I just I wanted
you guys to appreciate the production
value of these videos click here to what
did I say at the bottom was that's what
we're doing on the street instant
find out how I buck this hot [ __ ] and
you're just a loser you should give me
money someone paid a hundred dollars
tell you I gotta [ __ ] do this god I
need to start doing pickup seminars man
you could sell those guys big connect
coins for sure you could sell them
lioness cars good lioness oh man these
are the best
so speaking with the office is a running
theme in this episode there's another
pickup artist do you guys know who
Catherine Tate is she was in the office
she's an English comedian so this
[ __ ] genius saw her in Starbucks and
he's like I need to be alive
pickup session of Catherine Tate and
film it without a permission and put it
on YouTube
this guy [ __ ] you know this guy knows
how to touch here take the famous
comedian from the UK in the coffee shop
just behind me it was pret I'm on Jamie
and Edward getting some coffees for
ourselves basically what happened ed
noticed her and just for a laugh I
decided to approach and try and pick her
up it was a lot of fun
it was very spontaneous she was a cool
person we had a good laugh what you see
on camera in her in her comedy is kind
of what you get in real life she's like
a nice fun bubbly person sorry sorry
excuse me too loud I just wanted to come
and say hi because you're really cute
wrong with this guy walking around with
a hidden camera
he's like I'm ready to go I'm ready to
film anyone without their permission at
anytime whenever he started a video he
was across the street like you had like
binoculars she comes here around 1:00
p.m. every bucket they just spotted
Katherine tape got my hidden cam set up
I'm a spinner I give her syphilis that
way we'll be connected say no then cup
of water prank yeah [ __ ] here at my
dudes this Mike's got a smell I wish
y'all could smell this no 9:30
wait what time's the show in wait what
times is showing do we have 7 minutes
left
what oh no there's no way how the [ __ ]
that we can do our can we do it longer
they have another show booked oh there's
another show we could just see what
happens they're probably not gonna want
us back you guys can do it at my house
Oh God
you just go in the middle of the street
continue this [ __ ] I can't believe we
only have [ __ ] six minutes left what
a bummer dude
well [ __ ] this guy this guy's not worthy
of our last six minutes pull up the bit
connect in Samba oh man I had I had such
good man I had a [ __ ] video of a
beauty vlogger who gets semen well I
just want you guys to know what you're
missing she had she's a beauty vlogger
who gets semen from her friend not even
her lover and she applies it to her face
as a moisturizer
she's like Ikes this semen was not
extracted by me and then she has another
video where she drinks it as a [ __ ]
redbull what a killed man you got really
nice [ __ ] skin good you got some
really nice [ __ ] semen let's watch
this I can't believe we run out of time
let's watch the in Samba these guys are
great right there so these this really
needs no introduction I just want to
give a shout out to what is what's the
name of their Channel
[Music]
this is why music was invented feel like
it's a sport like a Disney it's built
it's powerful
we need Carlos has so much potential man
where is he
come back Carlos we miss you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I would watch a whole animated series of
this man yeah alright well can't without
time for the semen gags this was by to
set violin everybody at home is Jetta so
we can't without time for the semen gags
we don't have time we have h three deep
fakes maybe we've got time for that
pull that up you guys thought that deep
thing you don't know who this is this is
agent y'all I look like Nicolas Cage
whoa what a coincidence
it's like they put his face on me you
guys have heard of deep fakes where they
put like my face on porn stars so they
can get off to me because I never do
nudes it's the only way after that yeah
so now you can FAP to me guys
congratulations I in the face got him
now show us these really big luscious
beautiful dsl lips and if you take a
look at this picture you notice there
I'm very red very very pink and now it's
healthier to the logo of Verizon showing
me no actually before he was Nicolas
Cage's face I mean he was the general
counsel you get the idea all right so
before we end we have a special bit a
special act somebody wants to come up
here and say a couple words her route
are you out there my doggy is there her
route out there where is he oh here he
comes her Oh
[Applause]
hello hey nice to see you buddy
thank you go ahead oh thanks man I love
you too appreciate you a nice hat by the
way oh no it's gonna turn into a [ __ ]
pitch to bring you guys a historic I'm
actually here I wanted to go ahead and
thank you very much of course Wow what's
her name
Anna come up here goddamn it Anna Anna
get the hell up here goddamn it get up
here hey Anna how are you nice to see
you so I just wanted to go ahead and do
this I love you a lot and you know this
and I'd rather spend the rest of my life
with you then doing anything else and I
want you to be my wife oh wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god bless him I was wonderful good we
originally planning to do a call and
good thing we didn't do that
congratulations you guys [ __ ] hip
nationhood and guys just to keep the
hype going we need to keep the energies
high people have always told me I look
like Oprah so I thought hey I've got an
opportunity for everybody to look under
your seats what everybody look under
your seats there's something there
oh my god I'm Oprah oh that feels good
that feels good guys thank you everybody
for coming out that went by so friggin
fast thank you all so much y'all means
so much to us well blown away that went
by so fast man [ __ ] you look good in
that beanie dude look at this unreleased
orange beanie um by the way the hats
were just for the bit you guys are gonna
have to drop those out and I've been on
the way out and if anybody took to
nobody I'm gonna shame them like Ellen
Ellen guys really especially this guy
with the hat wearing hat I wanted to say
thank you to our crew Alex our wonderful
editor in the internal intern Sarah our
life switching badass of course Dan our
producer without whom none of this would
be possible love you guys thank you to
post Malone the greatest [ __ ] guy ever
thank you most of all like you're the
best dog I love you always ride or die
and of course we're mighty luck liners
out there Wow without without ela none
of this would have been possible cuz I
would have never made a single [ __ ]
video and guys I just I can't thank you
guys enough no yeah everyone's like no
huh
and guys you've been a terrific crowd
you've been a tough crowd you've been a
terrific crowd we've had our ups and
downs our dead air and our great here um
yeah this was so much fun man I just
[ __ ] sad to say goodbye so soon we
want to do it every month
yeah [ __ ] yeah love it
our plan is to do one every month I
think next time we'll try to get a
couple more seats so we got some more
yulik liners in here and maybe a couple
more [ __ ] hours as well yeah just
went by way too fast guys bands are
always so awkward I never know how to
finish it yeah all right bye everybody
just yes we have I don't know that it
was advertised well but we have some
exclusive merch only available to the
live audience which looks very cool it
the booth is outside do we have a
picture of the shirt or something that
we can show it's [ __ ] dope and we have
posters that we signed as well outside
so no I don't have that that's gonna
cost you more than ten bucks December
1st of next year so by that merch as
they say I don't know guys thank you for
coming out here man
it means the world we love you guys this
is [ __ ] unreal this is crazy
thank you guys I guess that's it
[Music]